the relationship between the world's top
two apex predators is a complicated one
in recent months there have been many
stories of orcas attacking boats ripping
their rudds off and sometimes even
sinking them in recent decades hordes of
human visitors have watched orcas at
SeaWorld perform tricks with their human
counterparts and we know that sometimes
those orcas kill their human
trainers and despite the fact that orcas
have never killed humans in the wild
that we know of humans are perhaps
rightfully fearful of these intelligent
cations we appreciate their magnificence
but there are few humans on this planet
who would willingly jump into the sea
alongside them but before the days of
SeaWorld for a certain time and in one
certain place humans didn't capture
orcas kill them or fear them they
instead befriended them working together
to hunt some of the largest creatures in
the ocean humpback and Southern right
whales it's a story about unimaginable
cooperation between two very different
species and a story about what happens
when trust is broken and sacred packs
are
abandoned in the deep water off the
eastern coast of Australia Southern
right whales and humpbacks swim by
during their annual migrations in the
summer towards the South to cooler
feeding water and in the winter back
North for for warmer Waters to breed in
the orcas in this region learned these
migration patterns and between April and
November they would lie and wait for
migrating baline whales on the
Southeastern tip of the continent and
then trap them and then devour them in
the confined Waters of two-fold bay for
thousands of years the Aboriginal people
of this area the UN Nation revered these
orcas with many of their beliefs linking
the people with the whales and when the
orcas herded the baline whales into the
bay the people were more easily able to
spear these whales for themselves this
long-standing Aboriginal tradition set
the stage for what would become the most
well-documented case of orca and human
cooperation in history when Europeans
arrived in the 19th century they took
advantage of the plentiful whales that
passed by the area every year one family
of Scottish Whalers the Davidsons set up
a wailing station on twofold Bay one of
the deepest natural Harbors in the
southern hemisphere the Aboriginal
people they worked with in the area
insisted that no killer whales be hunted
instead the settlers were taught how to
work with the orcas when the orcas found
a whale and herded it into the bay one
of them would break off to swim closer
to the whaling station at the entrance
to the Kia River then begin slapping its
tail on the water making a loud
percussive sound to to alert the humans
men would race out to their rowboats
equipped with harpoons and work with the
orcas to take down their prey once the
bloody hunt was complete the men would
leave the carcass anchored in place and
let the orcas have the first go the
orcas ate the lips and tongue of the
bailing whales then the humans returned
to harvest the rest of the Body for its
oil this exchange was known as the law
of the tongue and it continued for
decades through multi generations of the
Davidson family among the most famous
and recognizable of the Orca Partners
was a large male known as old Tom his
help was so invaluable that at one point
when George Davidson was knocked out of
a boat during a hunt Tom circled him in
the water protecting him from sharks
until he was retrieved by the other
humans the level of cooperation between
these humans and the orcas sounds almost
unbelievable but it was well documented
clearly it was mutually beneficial to
both species but it's also a rare
example of carnivores working together
humans and lions don't team up to go
after zebras nor do humans and polar
bears or any other large Predators so
why did the orcas do
it orcas have the second largest brain
in the animal kingdom following only
sperm whales this big brain contributes
not only to their High social behavior
and wide repertoire of sounds but also
to the way their pods develop distinct
cultures this is something we've
explored in great depth in our video
about orcas but what's more relevant for
the story of the Eden orcas is their
adaptive hunting ability orcas in
different locations develop different
hunting methods and even go after
different prey in some places orcas will
purposefully Beach themselves to attack
seals and sea lions in other places orc
oras will eat anything that comes into
their Waters including birds and even
moose they are the ocean's apex predator
thanks to their large brains and dietary
flexibility they're perfectly poised to
take advantage of whatever new things
come into their environment and when
that new element was human Whale hunters
the orcas seemed more than happy to make
use of us after all in one single season
the Eden Whale hunters were able to take
in 22 two baline whales that meant a lot
of oil for the humans and a lot of lip
and tongue meat for the orcas but sadly
the partnership was doomed to meet an
untimely
End by the early 1900s Bine whale
populations had plummeted due to
extensive hunting by humans around the
world this meant fewer and fewer
opportunities for cooperation between
the orcas and the humans though it still
happened on rare occasions
that was the case in 1923 when George
Davidson went out with a friend named
John Logan to their surprise old Tom
suddenly appeared hurting a humpback
whale towards them Davidson managed to
spear the whale but instead of anchoring
it in the water as was the tradition
Logan insisted that they immediately
bring it back in with them a storm was
coming and he didn't want the hump back
to be washed away a tug of war ensued
between the boat and old Tom the Orca
tried pulling the lines with his teeth
as if insisting he get his rightful
share of the prey but then one of his
teeth broke off a possible death
sentence for an orca as such injuries
can lead to deadly infections and the
inability to eat it's reported that
Logan fell to his knees and said oh god
what have I done he understood the
possible consequences of the battle with
old Tom and he knew that an ancient pact
had been broken old Tom survived in the
wild for seven more years and when his
body washed ashore in 1930 it was
discovered that his missing teeth had
turned into abscesses and his stomach
was empty he'd starved Logan still felt
so terrible about what had happened that
he helped build a museum about orcas
into which old Tom's skeleton was placed
it's still there today along with
stories about the orcas and the other
whale species of the region so was it
this human betrayal that led to the end
of cooperation between our two species
or were other factors at play some
researchers think that the orcas
themselves were being hunted in other
areas and this led to their dwindling
numbers before that fateful incident
with Logan and old Tom but based on Old
Tom's Behavior it also seems clear that
he felt betrayed by the human's decision
whether the orcas ever would have
started hunting with humans again is
impossible to say the Eden wailing
operation shut down in 1929 and wailing
has been outlawed since then but
recently orcas were once more spotted
around twofold Bay maybe they're ready
to forgive the humans even if we're no
longer helping them get the best parts
of their baing prey the interaction
between humans and nature is an area of
Investigation I deeply love I am
fascinated to understand how ancient
traditions of humans allowed our
ancestors to survive in so many
environments around the world my videos
on YouTube occasionally touch on this
but to really really start to understand
what it would have taken to survive in
an ancient environment I made a show
that puts me to the test very literally
in tasks that Paleolithic humans would
have needed to excel at to survive in
this five-part docu game show called
archaeology Quest me and my riding
partner Lorraine compete against each
other in tasks that range from pottery
making spear throwing to mushroom
foraging with the ultimate question who
will succeed in creating a meal using
only Paleolithic technology this show is
only available on nebula and right now
the first two episodes are live we just
released episode 2 which details our
attempts at creating stone tools and
putting them to the test it was so much
harder than it looks but will the tools
we make be able to cut hack and slash
things in the end this is the biggest
project I've ever taken on and it's a
mix of serious archaeology education
alongside our ridiculous and funny
attempts to actually try out what we've
learned it was all possible thanks to
nebula so to watch the first two
episodes head over to
curiosity stream has informed us that
they don't intend to pay us for any
bundle Revenue in 2024 even for the
accounts that still have access if you
purchased a bundle subscription or
renewed in 2023 you will still get
access to nebula until the end of your
12month subscription but unfortunately
going forward none of the money will go
to nebula and therefore it won't go to
the creators you likely signed up to
support we know we're not happy about
this either if if you're a bundle user
and still want to support this channel
by being a nebulous subscriber in 2024
the only way to be sure your money goes
towards supporting us and nebula is by
signing up directly for bundle
subscribers if you switch to a direct
nebula subscription you'll sign up and
pay today but we won't start the clock
until your bundle access expires signing
up to nebula is the best way you can
support this channel it's how we can
afford to bring you new videos every
month so if you sign up using the link
below you can support this channel
directly and get both nebula and nebula
classes for 40% off the annual plan a
little over $25 per month nebula is the
only place you can watch archaeology
Quest and tons of other original content
so go to